[vent qui souffle]
[chuchote] Bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo d'ASMR.
Vous savez on est le 9 décembre, vous savez ce que ça veut dire ?
Pour vous c'est pas grand chose, mais pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup, parce que le 9 décembre
Je serai arrivé au Mexique en vacances !
Mais, ce qui n'empêchera pas d'être présent dans les commentaires quand cette vidéo là sortira.
J'avais envie, avant de vous parler du petit livre, ou produit du jour, ou truc que je kiffe que je voulais vous présenter,
avant d'ouvrir ce calendrier de l'Avent des cadeaux de Noël,
vous parler du contexte en mémoire qui est une piste de réflexion,
un petit peu comme l'autre jour où je vous ai parlé du corps humain pour le palais mental
j'ai une piste qui mérite peut-être pas d'en faire une vidéo entière comme on fait tout le reste de l'année
mais qui, je crois sera intéressante, sur le fait de toujours chercher à contextualiser sa mémoire.
Pareil il y a quelques jours, à savoir le 4 décembre,
je vous ai parlé de comment apprendre le morse, et on a commencé à parler vite fait de synesthésie,
par rapport aux sons et à ce code-là.
Si vous faites travailler le contexte,
lorsque vous voulez apprendre une information, vous allez faire travailler plusieurs choses,
à savoir aussi peut-être l'odorat, à savoir l'ouïe, peut-être le goût c'est tout à fait possible,
et des émotions particulières, bon... qui ne rentrent pas dans la synesthésie, mais qui sont intéressantes.
Pourquoi ? Parce que, en fixant toute cette information,
vous allez encore créer des associations comme je vous ai dit l'autre jour, qui vont renforcer
l'assemblage de souvenirs préexistants en vous, parce que ça reste que ça, la mémoire.
Encore une fois, c'est assez rare qu'on y rentre une nouvelle donnée brute
Et là, vous dites "Mais, Fabien,
comment je fais pour travailler le contexte ?"
Eh bien, merci de l'avoir posée, la lampe !
Vous devez vous concentrer,
quand vous cherchez à vous rappeler quelque chose ou à réviser
de quand ou comment dans quel état d'esprit était le moment de l'apprentissage, est-ce que vous étiez en train d'apprendre en cours, chez vous
à votre bureau etc, etc...
En temps normal ça va être assez simple
de se souvenir mais ça va pas vous provoquer quelque chose de particulier parce que trop quotidien et vous apprenez toujours régulièrement dans le même
contexte. Maintenant imaginez que vous avez un cours à apprendre
particulier et c'est très important d'apprendre ce cours.
Au lieu de l'apprendre chez vous dans votre chambre sur votre lit, vous décidez d'aller apprendre ce cours là
dans un parc près de chez vous. Pour aller à ce parc,
vous mettez une musique particulière, celle que vous écoutez en ce moment et vous allez à pied jusqu'à ce parc en essayant déjà sur le
trajet de vous rappeler de ce qui vous est resté
spontanément de ce cours que vous avez appris à l'école, juste pour faire un petit état des lieux.
Vous arrivez dans le parc, vous vous posez dans l'herbe, au sol, pour garder un petit peu ce qui se passe autour de vous,
vous pouvez laisser la musique (ou non), suivant comment vous fonctionnez pour travailler. Moi je sais que j'apprends plutôt avec de la musique.
Vous respirez un petit peu les odeurs qu'il y a, vous prenez un chewing gum
particulier un goût que vous ne prenez pas d'habitude par exemple un chewing gum à l'abricot et là vous travaillez sur votre cours avec vos techniques de mémorisation
habituelles du cours. Lorsque vous allez devoir vous rappeler plus tard
de ce cours pour le restituer, que ce soit lors d'une interro ou lors d'une discussion ou pour votre culture générale,
vous allez voir que, assez spontanément, ce contexte particulier d'apprentissage va vous revenir, peut-être le goût du chewing gum, peut-être le trajet,
peut-être le parc en lui-même, l'odeur du parc, les sons qu'il y avait dans le parc...
l'état d'esprit détendu que vous aviez quand vous êtes assis au niveau émotionnel... Mais tout ça va renforcer, en fait va fixer,
d'une manière différente, votre mémoire.
Donc voilà, je pense qu'il y a une bonne piste à travailler du côté du contexte.
Je crois que je le faire moi aussi un peu plus régulièrement et à terme je vous en ferai une vidéo
sur tous les avantages/inconvénients que j'en ai ressorti, mais je voulais partager ce contexte avec vous.
Avant d'achever cette vidéo, comme d'habitude, nous sommes dans un calendrier de l'Avent donc j'ai préparé un petit quelque chose pour vous qui est ici !
Autour de moi ! Dans les particules ! Et si je regarde ici ça veut dire qu'il est en train d'apparaître juste ici !
Voilà, il s'agit du "Big Bang Pour Les Nuls". Qui peut monter d'ailleurs ou descendre.
Et les mauvaises langues diront que c'est en post prod alors qu'il est vraiment ici: "Le Big Bang Pour Les Nuls" expliqué simplement.
C'est une version mise à jour.
Alors, ceux qui me connaissent un peu de la scène etc, savent que je suis passionné
vraiment par le Big Bang, et tu vas te dire dans ces cas là si tu es passionné: "Pourquoi tu lis de nouvelles choses ?"
Parce qu'on n'en sait rien encore !
On croit qu'on sait mais c'est bien souvent des hypothèses, et certaines se révèlent être fausses, d'autres vraies et on avance comme ça.
Ca c'est une version qui est mise à jour.
Moi, ce que j'aime bien dans la collection "Pour Les Nuls", c'est que voilà, il y a toujours une charte, une manière de traiter les choses, un certain humour,
et je trouve que cette version là, faite par la physicienne Blandine Puchet est...
très complète et en même temps très concise
et assez drôle à lire avec des anecdotes que je ne connaissais pas
donc si vous aimez ce délire là je vous recommande ce livre dont je mets le lien dans la description,
juste en dessous de mon lien pour les places à l'Olympia, qui s'appelle "Singularité".
et "Singularité" c'est en référence au Big Bang justement, et ça, vous le comprendrez lors du final du spectacle.
Dont j'espère tu viendras, tu peux mettre un pouce en l'air si tu as aimé la vidéo et t'abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait,
le calendrier de l'Avent c'est une vidéo par jour à 6H du matin tous les jours, jusqu'au 24 décembre.
A demain donc !
Ciao !
[musique]